[Musik]
in tirol und salzburg gibt es ab sofort
die neuen hätte uns das sind in schweden
gefertigte gefechtsfahrzeuge die an die
spezifisch österreichischen
anforderungen angepasst worden sind die
freude über das neue gefechts fahrzeug
ist entsprechend groß da die
gebirgstruppe bisher über keine
gepanzerten transportmöglichkeiten
verfügt hat der geförderte reynard
weiter
das gilt derzeit für unsere
oberschenkeln unsere sie jetzt haben wir
auch ein fahrzeug dass es dorthin bringt
das alte rain almeida und protection
gewährleistet und somit bringt uns das
einen großen schritt nach vorne für uns
ist natürlich auch heute ein besonderer
tag für die salzburger pioniere in der
sechs brigade aber heute gerät bekommen
haben das für uns einsatz wichtig ist
und wozu unsere frühling unsere aufgabe
uns einen weiteren schritt nach vorne
bringt das kettenfahrzeug ist für den
einsatz im hochgebirge besonders gut
geeignet das rundum kamera system bietet
ein 360 grad sicht fällt vom geschützten
innenraum aus
so wie in italien fahren mit masse nur
mit jeder fahrzeugen bis auf wenige der
bergepanzer und pionierpanzer aber das
kettenfahrzeug insofern ungewöhnlich es
besteht aus zwei teilen haben einen
fahrer wagen einen hinterfragen
es ist die art zu lenken etwas
ungewöhnlich also man muss schon wissen
was man noch bei einer gefechts
vorführung in salzburg wird die
einsatztauglichkeit des neuen gefechts
fahrzeugs unter beweis gestellt
die bewaffnung des hegel uns gilt als
über schwer
das maschinengewehr hat ein kaliber von
12,7 millimeter
insgesamt werden 32 fahrzeuge im
gesamtwert von rund 85 millionen euro
angeschafft für verteidigungsminister
mario kunasek ist hier jeder euro
richtig investiert auf alle fälle hat
die richtige investition wurde hier
getroffen eine stärkung der
gebirgstruppe auf ein gerät ausgerichtet
was dringend notwendig ist und was die
motivation auch steigert man spürt einem
positiven geist und ich bin stolz dass
wir das in relativ kurzen zeit geschafft
haben
jetzt liegt der ball bei der truppe
auszubilden das gerät sozusagen 1 zu
phasen in das system und dann letztlich
auch in den einsatz zu geben